[Music]
foreign
[Music]
most of us just love a good film
Malaysian but it's pretty hard to
understand how to create effect in such
a way that it's rendering a natural and
subtle relation bleeding so in today's
video I'll show you exactly how I
correct the best solution settings and
how to understand what each slider is
actually doing before we start it took
me quite some time experimenting and
testing hundreds of shots to find these
settings so why not hit the like button
and share this video with other people
that might need this in their workflow
okay no more time wasting let's get into
DaVinci enter the color tab either
pressing on it or hitting hotkey shift 4
on Windows or command 4 on Mac in the
upright Corner hit the effects menu and
search for halation
drag it on top of the desired node and
let's start analyzing the first options
we'll be working with
first thing we have color space
processing Either Leave it to your
project timeline input or you can open
and choose a type of color space you
have shot it in this particular video
was shot on a cinechrome Sony film
simulation recipe which uses a BT 2020
color space so I'll just go ahead and
choose BT 2020
these Sony film simulations are based
off the picture profile menu so if
you're interested in film simulations
just go check my website for the picture
profile settings back to the halation
menu
you can leave the isolation and the die
layer as they are for the moment and
let's jump directly to the secondary
glow I will guide you through a couple
adjustments and afterwards I will
explain what and why
so bring up the strength and lift the
gamma all the way to the top
as you can see the halation is pretty
gross right now is already showing very
strongly throughout the image so bring
down the spread
foreign
looks better but the colors are still
very vibrant the main problem here is
the secondary glow color is bright red
so let's change the color of the filter
to a dark brown tone and that will solve
most of our problems
so as a basic explanation halation takes
place in areas of high contrast usually
between sky and Dark Shadow so what I've
done here actually is I've boosted the
power and the contrast of the secondary
glow to make sure the hellish will show
up even in areas of lower contrast like
between branches for example and reduce
the spread to a minimum so it's not
bleeding all over the place making it
present over the whole image but in a
very subtle way also I've changed the
initial color of the halation effect
which was very bright and vibrant the
darker shade of orange and that is meant
to solve the color brightness problem
while also giving natural tone down
halation effect
it's looking great already some people
like this kind of a look and they can
stop right here but for a more natural
and organic look let's continue with a
couple Minor Adjustments hit a die layer
reflection bring down the strength just
by a bench and you can bring up the
gamma to increase solution in areas of
lower contrast
that's your choice
you can also adjust the spread level
even more to reduce or increase the
bleeding of the resolution effect
and there is also relative spread which
can be shown by checking this box he
here you can balance out individual
color channels like red green and blue
favoring one over the other will make it
more dominant but we'll leave this for
another video
next and final steps
in the isolation submenu set the
Threshold at your desired level each
clip will require a different threshold
level since each clip will have a
different highlight point so adjust it
your own liking and depending how much
of the image you want affected by the
Revelation lastly film saturation this
is again your personal choice but I
would recommend going for something very
subtle from 0.10 to 0.35 I've included
these settings in my cine Rec 16
millimeter film print together with more
refined color adjustments that will give
you authentic film look which can be
used on any kind of footage Rec 709 or
log 10 bit and even 8-bit I've tested it
on the new area Alexa 35 cinema camera
and it looks great you can go check out
that video I put a link in the upright
Corner if you like these settings give
this video a like and share it with
people all my field packs come with
multiple color palette variations to
give you more options to choose from and
you can find a power grid on my website
go check it out Link in description down
below you can also download the basic
Note 3 which has violation settings in
it or other free Luts on my website so
this is it for the video till next time
have fun and take care see ya
[Music]